supongamos que el año pasado abrir un
restaurante le voy a poner por aquí un
restaurante restaurant y quiero ver que
también me fue en el año es decir cuál
fue mi utilidad resulta que hay dos
formas de ver esto una es a través de la
utilidad contable le voy a poner aquí
utilidad utilidad contable contable y la
otra forma de verlo es a través de la
utilidad económica utilidad económica
económica muy bien la utilidad contable
es pues lo que casi toda la gente piensa
cuando habla acerca de utilidad es decir
veces cuánto ganas te le restas cuánto
gastas te y eso es lo que te da la
utilidad económica es un poco distinta
en realidad no solo es el ingreso
después de los gastos sino que además es
incierto en cierta forma nos dicen si
tiene sentido continuar con el negocio o
no entonces pues ahorita vamos a ver
cómo distinguirlas y para eso lo mejor
es hacer las cuentas para este negocio
del restaurante entonces vamos a ver un
ejemplo supongamos que estamos en el año
1 aquí le voy a poner que es el año 1
y este es el estado de resultados es
decir a signos fue en el año los
ingresos por ventas le voy a poner aquí
ingresos ingresos fue de 500 mil pesos
no va a poner 500 mil para esto ya que
es lo que pagaron los clientes entonces
es todo lo que nos llegó en efectivo y
ahora los gastos aquí va a poner gastos
fueron varios por un lado tenemos el
gasto pues de la comida comida digamos
que de esto fue 100 mil pesos esto es
comprar la materia prima y los
ingredientes y las especias además
tenemos labor que hay que pagar si de
labor pensemos que son también 100 mil
pesos
esto de aquí es pagarle los sueldos a
los meseros al administrador al chef a
los cocineros y así también vamos a
pensar que nuestro restaurante ahorita
bueno la verdad no es nuestro sino que
pagamos un espacio y entonces tenemos
que pagar renta del edificio va a poner
así la más renta va entonces tenemos que
pagar la renta y eso nos cuesta digamos
200 mil pesos
y además supongamos que el equipo
tampoco es nuestro tenemos que rentar
las cacerolas y las sillas y pues toda
la vajilla y así entonces además de la
renta del equipo tenemos que pagar 50
mil pesos 50 mil ok entonces déjame
poner una línea aquí para ver cuánto nos
da y entonces los ingresos antes de
impuestos esto es importante verdad que
sean antes de impuestos porque después
hay que sacar el impuesto si lo que sea
pero los ingresos antes de impuestos de
impuestos
y puestos cuánto es pues los ingresos
antes de impuestos es estos 500 mil y a
estos 500 mil hay que restarle esto de
acá 100 y 100 son 200 y 200 son 400 y 50
450 450 para 500 mil son 50 entonces
aquí nos quedan 50 mil pesos muy bien
entonces esto de aquí son los ingresos
antes de impuestos y esto lo vamos a
considerar como la utilidad porque
después dependiendo de donde vivas a lo
mejor vives en eeuu o vives en francia o
vives no sé en argentina y entonces
pueden ser distintos los impuestos que
te toca pagar entonces esto de acá lo
vamos a pensar como la utilidad contable
simplemente es a los ingresos que
obtenemos por ventas le restamos todos
los gastos va después que puedes hacer
con este dinero pues no sé o sea con
este dinero a lo mejor todavía tengas
que pagar un poco de deuda verdad tienes
que pagar intereses oa lo mejor el
restaurante es tuyo y lo puedes usar
para pagar tus propias cuentas o incluso
puedes reinvertir ese dinero entonces
este dinero puede irte sea puede
reinvertir se verdad al negocio
y entonces ahora si puedes empezar a
comprar tu vajilla o lo que sea no puede
ser para para ti me va a poner si para
ti si ya te lo quedas si lo usas para
pagar su renta si lo que sea muy bien
después vamos a ver ejemplos más
complicados de esto con esto de de los
impuestos y de las reinversiones pero
pues básicamente utilidad contable es
esto es lo que se entiende por utilidad
comúnmente y es a los ingresos le
restamos todos los gastos bueno ahora
vamos a pasar a utilidad económica la
idea es muy similar sólo que los
economistas hablan en términos un poco
distintos vale entonces vamos a usar
otro tipo de palabras pero es más o
menos lo mismo entonces una vez más
vamos a pensar que estamos en el año 1
en el año 1 y que de nuevo tenemos de
ingresos 500 mil pesos bajo ingresos son
500 mil pesos muy bien hasta ahí todo va
igual
la cosa es que los economistas no
piensan las cosas en términos de costos
o de gastos sino que lo piensan en
términos de costos de oportunidad es
decir lo piensan en términos de ok ya
pagamos algo pero eso lo pudimos haber
utilizado en otro negocio entonces para
los economistas también tenemos gastos o
costos lo voy a poner aquí pero se les
conoce como costos de de oportunidad
oportunidad y ahora dentro de los costos
de oportunidad hay de dos tipos uno son
los implícitos y otros son los
explícitos los explícitos son estos
mismos de acá sí explícitos explícitos
son la comida labor renta y equipo
entonces le voy a poner así ya damos
abreviado comida labor renta y equipo
entonces aquí son 100 mil pesos
aquí también son 100 mil pesos acá son
200.000 y acá son 50.000 ok
hasta ahí todo igual sin embargo hay
otro tipo de costos estos se llaman
explícitos porque pues efectivamente
aquí hay dinero que está saliendo del
negocio y podemos verlo en las cuentas
verdad podemos verlo en los cheques de
los trabajadores o en los recibos de los
distribuidores entonces es dinero que
está saliendo aquí explícitamente son
cuentas que estamos pagando
explícitamente pero el otro tipo de
costos de oportunidad son con costos de
oportunidad implícitos
y tienen que ver con este dinero que
estamos usando o este negocio que
estamos haciendo qué otro tipo de
ingresos nos está impidiendo tener bueno
entonces dentro de los costos implícitos
podríamos pensar no sé pensemos en
salarios perdidos me voy a poner aquí
salarios salarios perdidos
perdidos ya qué me refiero con salarios
perdidos pues a lo mejor tú eres un
magnífico taxista y a cada eres la onda
y puedes ganar dinero si te decidís y en
vez de andar manejando un restaurante
pues te dedicas a manejar un taxi
entonces digamos que no sé qué por
salarios perdidos en este año por no
haber sido un taxista además estás
perdiendo 150 mil pesos al año entonces
por esto son costos implícitos no es
como que alguien a alguien le estés
pagando 150 mil sino que más bien en vez
de estar en un restaurant podrías estar
manejando un taxi y ganar ya estoy acá
entonces eso ya no lo estás ganando y
por tanto esto queda considerado en
estos costos de oportunidad bueno vamos
a ver cuánto nos queda aquí
a esa línea quedó súper sueca vamos a
ponerla con la herramienta de línea y
así está mejor ok entonces son 500.000 y
aquí dijimos que había que restar
450.000 entonces estamos en estar acá en
50.000 pero luego hay que restar otros
150.000 entonces nos quedarían menos
100.000 menos 100.000 va entonces como
se llama estoy acá estoy acá es la
utilidad contable el de la izquierda
entonces estoy acá le voy a poner
utilidad utilidad contable contable y
estoy acá es la utilidad económica
utilidad económica
no me digas pero ve estoy aquí es
negativo y qué quiere decir que estoy
aquí sea negativo o sea claramente no
quiere decir que el restaurante no se
esté haciendo pagar dinero si no es como
que este restaurant cada año esté
perdiendo dinero de hecho el restaurante
está ganando 50 mil pesos al año pero lo
que nos dice esto de acá que la utilidad
económica sea negativa es que pues más
bien hay otras cosas hay otros este
bueno otras actividades que podemos
hacer que nos convienen más que manejar
este restaurante o al menos más que
manejarlo como lo hemos estado manejando
hasta ahorita a lo mejor esto de andar
pagando renta es muy caro y nos
convendría tener nuestro propio edificio
y así pero al menos visto en este año
hay otras actividades que nos convino
hacer más que manejar el restaurant como
lo estábamos haciendo si esto fuera cero
entonces sería neutral
ahí ya tengas que pensar si le echas más
ganas al restaurant o si te vas de
taxista depende de que te guste más y si
es positivo entonces ahora si es que si
te conviene más el restaurante incluso
considerando que podrías andar manejando
tu taxi bueno entonces utilidad contable
dice cuánto
efectivo genera el negocio si cuánto
dinero puede puede crear cada año verdad
y por otro lado la utilidad económica
nos dice comparado con otras
posibilidades si tiene sentido o no
seguir con el negocio en este caso de
aquí si eres racional y tomas todas tus
decisiones basadas en dinero entonces te
vas a dar cuenta que no conviene tener
el restaurante y es mucho mejor irse de
taxista